nous avec les mangas au journaliste
directeur du magazine l'afrique
aujourd'hui
bonsoir vivant et au mercy d'être avec
nous on imagine que cette disparition a
vécu comme un séisme dans la campagne
présidentielle
absolument c'est le cas si ce n'est ces
décès brutal et inattendu mais en même
temps il faut quand même mesuré dans que
l'ampleur de cette triste 1 qui frappe
toute la côte d'ivoire
mais c'est amadou gon coulibaly était
effectivement mal à les rites et amis en
france en phase d'hospitalisation qui a
duré pratiquement deux mois et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de polémiques sur
le toit quoi tu vois or il qu'ils
étaient annoncés plus d'une fois et
finalement il est rentré mais
malheureusement voilà quelques jours
dans deux trois divas voilà que il
décède après une réunion du conseil des
ministres est vraiment un véritable choc
au la côte d'ivoire notamment pour son
parti qui est le présent qui lui est
d'ailleurs candidat ou à la
présidentielle d'octobre 2020 on va y
revenir sur ces présidentielles on voit
qu'il ya une véritable émotion dans la
population
qu'est-ce qu'ils incarnaient monsieur
coulibaly en côte d'ivoire la jeune
génération mais pas que disons que là
dessus les avis sont vraiment partagé
effectivement c'était elle était grand
serviteur de l'état de quoi dit voilà
c'est dire puisque postes de
responsabilités notamment au niveau du
bureau national des travaux qui est
d'abord qu'est-ce que tout ce qui est
travaux dont le parcours rappelle
bennett n'a été un responsable ensuite
la série d'ailleurs depuis 90 est il
était conseiller technique du président
alassane ouattra au temps où il était
premier ministre
ensuite bon ils étaient 102 les
télécabines et celles issues des bons je
la termine en tant que premier ministre
faites moi un grand serviteur de l'état
de côte-d'ivoire
maintenant de là dit qu' il est vraiment
les candidats pourtant c'est qu'ils
pourraient donc continuer de la loire la
savoie tracé su qu'il ya tout et toute
la semaine les débats parce qu'au sein
du parti dont temps qu'il dont il
représentait le rhdp qui est tolérable
le rassemblement des fautifs ou la
démocratie et la paix il y avait déjà
les avis étaient partagés
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a poussé
certaines sont ils ces partis j'ai fait
la révision mais c'est un autre
on quittait donc le chef de la
diplomatie ivoirienne par le passé qui
est donc qui a dû donc takla pas sorti
du rhdp
voilà le sujet les avis sont partagés
effectivement grâce évitez de l'état de
côte-d'ivoire et c'était surtout l'un
des favoris à cette présidentielle
d'octobre
est ce qu'on imagine maintenant
quelqu'un je sais mon sein du parti pour
pour lui succéder on imagine que c'est
c'est voilà une double perte pour ce
parti qui était attaché à lui qui perd
un candidat effectivement potentiel
favori oui oui enfin voler oui du moment
il est fils est quand même du bieler est
jugée assez positif de prison ouattara
qui est donc important et donc là dessus
c'est vrai est patent de ce bilan
positif qui porte d'ailleurs qui en tant
que premier ministre l'averse et s et es
davantage maintenant eux ou leurs ip il
est déçu que après l'émotion
les responsables de ces partis vont
penser à une pièce dirait changement
avec aimé péret le champ des robes
faussement le candidat qui sera désigné
je pense que moi mon analyse personnelle
le plaisant votre allumé finira pas y
aller parce que il n'a pas dit pendant
tout le temps qu'il a fait donc il a
fairy tale est donc on sont sa décision
la fille n'est parfait son choix sont si
son premier ministre
mais en même temps il était lui aussi
tenté loyer aller il avait même annoncé
à l'époque que si jamais eu se dessine à
gérer sa génération et est candidat cela
ne l'empêcherait pas d'y aller lui même
puisque la constitution actuelle lui
permettre de briguer un troisième mandat
pardonnez-moi la formulation de cette
question mais à qui profite entre
guillemets un politiquement cette
disparition justement dans la course à
cette présidentielle
mais il savait civique serait cynique
grado c'est là que hélas mois du groupe
balco fuite à pied ou à paul mais ceci
est il que ont fait le constat que
vikings ont cru baline deux plats un
candidat du rhdp qui était quand même
quand à potentiel de ces partis je vois
pas d'autres personnalités qui
pourraient incarner un peu tout ce que
de se battre a voulu mettre ce
personnage donc au risque de me répéter
je dirais que présentera lui mais c'est
l'attenté d'y aller parce que en dehors
du gon coulibaly tu vois pas d'autre
candidat qui pourrait donc ses
substituts
allez merci beaucoup clément yao d'avoir
été avec nous en direct de côte d'ivoire
merci